I like welcome to we can agree with me
Jane second Kevin McGuire and andrew
pearson here to look back at the biggest
stories of the last seven days before we
get started let's get a taste of what
the week was all about at least three
Britons were among 150 people killed
when a plane crashed in the French Alps
and it's emerged the pilot was locked
out of the cockpit focus shifted to the
copilot who activated the descent button
and refused to open the door he was
reported to have suffered from
depression in politics ed Miliband and
David Cameron did battle for number ten
live on Sky News and channel 4 I think
we're turning this country around i'm
passionate about having another term am
I toughen us I top it off hell yes I'm
tough enough if he does retain the keys
to number 10 of the election cameron
also said this week that he won't seek a
third term he tip to resume boris
johnson or george osborne for the job on
your bike Jeremy Clarkson was finally
dropped by the BBC after punching and
verbally abusing the top gear producer
US Senator Ted Cruz became the first
Republican to seek his party's
nomination to run for president in 2016
I holy delivery on a papal tour to
Naples no word yet whether the Polka
picked pepperoni and passengers in
Brazil had a lucky escape scrambling to
safety moments before the bus they were
travelling in we suddenly swallowed by a
sinkhole we talked a lot about politics
for last day or so but the big story of
the week was that desperate plane
crashed in the Alps wasn't it no
absolute absolute Lee and it's an
accident you wonder how it's happened
now it looks like the copilot is
deliberately crushing that plane killing
150 people 450 miles an hour no chance
it raised questions on medical checks
for pilots who've been suffering mental
illness problems depression and also the
whole idea the Fort Knox doll was to
stop terrorists getting into the [ __ ]
pic taken over planes and crushing them
but it allowed the copilot to lock out
his colleague early so that's now got to
be addressed a bit also an America after
911 they had a rule in the cockpit
buddies are all there has to be at least
two people in the cockpit the whole time
so now finally easyjet monarch and other
adopting that British Airways won't tell
us if they're going to do it because
they say they don't discuss security not
very reassuring if you're a British
Airways passenger as a story it was it
was a profoundly affecting a story
anyway because of the number of children
who were on board the youngsters but
then for a day later to hear that they
knew they were going to die in that the
screams could be heard the idea that the
other pilot was banging on the door
trying to get in and that descent took
eight minutes and the screams it was at
the press conference actually watching
on Sky News was one of the most chilling
I've ever watched it is the unimaginable
horror of being in that plane and what
that was mean now for the families and
friends of those those who died and it
is it just always too terrifying to try
and comprehend also the family of the
pilots himself because you imagine that
they have lost their side also yeah they
were on my way to the airport with all
the other people who died on board not
having an inkling that their son is a
serial killer and murderer let's move on
to politics now and it has been a big
week some say the start of the election
campaign proper ed Miliband and David
Cameron faced a live audience and a
grilling from Jeremy Paxman and Kay
Burley as they began the battle for
number ten the live event held by Sky
News and channel 4 kicked off the
campaign the two men setting out their
stalls for why they should be in power
can be eight of May Joe Jones has more
no preamble Jeremy Paxman wasn't hanging
around how's this for a first question
David Cameron do you know how many food
banks there were in this country when
you came to power I don't have the exact
figures but I know that usage of food
banks has gone up rattled you betty was
this was way out of the comfort zone
talk about zero hours contracts only
piled on the agony could you live on one
now look something as I said something
for what you have I want to create a
country where more people have the
opportunity of the full time work that
they want could you sippin on zero-hours
contract but it's not that's not the
question the studio audience format that
followed is much more up David Cameron
Street for example this could have been
tricky Prime Minister what do you think
our ed Miliband's best qualities but the
prime minister took the heat out of the
situation look I think all of us who
put ourselves forward or actually
believe in serving the public in trying
to do the right thing and so he clawed
it back still a rueful looking David
Cameron at the end knowing this was not
a vintage performance next up where the
Prime Minister had been tense ed
miliband hand in pocket and all seemed
not to be the mood had lifted but there
were tricky issues this one the
trickiest of all do you not think that
your brother would have done a better
job I thought somebody need to lead the
load buddy you could move us on from New
Labour I wonder though Mr Miliband what
regrets you have about creating such
division in your family it's hard it's
hard I make no bones but in what way is
out well there was bruising I mean you
know as bruising for me it was bruising
for David it's it's healed or healing i
would say when it came to the one-on-one
interview the Miliband policy was to
concede some ground on immigration when
your party was last in government it got
immigration completely Roger but then to
get on the offensive don't be so
presumptuous got six weeks to go got six
weeks to go you don't get to decide the
election results six weeks before the
general you're important Jeremy but not
that important it's a brighter water
bribery it's a pretty high reportedly
side no come on the most telling section
was about whether Ed Miliband has the
steel for the top job but am I toughen
us tough enough hell yes I'm tough
enough do you think um could that be
parodied in the days ahead hell yes but
Ed Miliband had the air of a man
demanding to be taken seriously and I've
been underestimated at every turn he in
short game on so do you think the best
yeah I think I think Joey Jones got it
right that Miliband was demanding to be
taken seriously I think it was taken
seriously people will look at him
slightly differently now the instant
poll showed David Cameron just one but
of the undecided voters who watched to
the one they went with EDD Miliband the
audience seemed to warm to Miliband more
there was more applause for Miliband
those more interaction but maybe that
was also because the audience had
relaxed a little bit by then yeah I
think that was a factor but also people
don't really know wed Miliband they've
seen him caricatured by Tory boy
and others defend of course every core
of course he's got his false he's not
perfect anymore than David Cameron's
perfect but I think people are slightly
surprised and they give him a second
look and that's what he wanted he wanted
a hearing and he's getting a hearing
anything Bobby the right Mel abandoned
me did all right he did okay I think
Cameron was very tense at the beginning
and you'd have thought we'd have learned
from the last time with the TV debates
when he was absolutely atrocious in the
first debate against Clegg and even gone
Brown beat him I think he got better and
i think he was better with the audience
even though interesting there was more
applause from the audience at mehriban
but i think he was also a disadvantage
going first and he was very nerdy do you
think Cameron's a bit complacent we've
seen him before it with the chillaxing
part-time prime minister became because
he was so it was useful he was so
useless in the last debate you'd have
thought he'd boomers perhaps he's just
not very good at that sort of thing but
actually the poll showed 54 to 46 that's
quite comfortable at the times I think
there's a two-point lead and the
undecided of course that was a two to
one per minute man that was only 90
people you know that 5446 it's an eight
point gap normally Cameron is polling
2030 ahead Miliband that's the
difference all of a sudden Miliband gets
that gets on TV people can see directly
what he's like and it's why I watching
those debates you could see why Cameron
is scared of a head-to-head I went a bit
silly the both got the studio but
they're not in at the same time but mmm
there we are that's a way that's way it
was it didn't want to go ahead to head
to head because he knows Miliband is
better than he says and Cameron had
difficulty defending his record
particularly on inequality on the area
of food banks and 0 I was one day they
sometimes there can be too rehearsed
that line about Jeremy pacsun your
import but not that imports so obviously
rehearse but it seemed to work by the
line about your on tough enough who's
eating his job way when I do he's going
on and I've got a heart here and I'm
also sarah palin you coined that line
wasn't it somebody idiot she's and he
won't want to be parodied line of
accidental Alan Partridge but that's
part of the appeal it shows a sense of
humor let's have a look at some of the
social media responses to what people
said David Mitchell's first one we had
look at seems David Cameron's been
called into the Headmaster's office for
a serious talking to a lot of people
thought that the first the first
from Jeremy Paxman especially where I
think a big child abuse in most schools
yeah listen for the next one John
Stevens were the matching outfits
compulsory they weren't clear verde yeah
they had gone to a lot of thought and
agonizing over all that actually maybe
they have the same advisors yeah
somebody's making a fortune and and this
this craze a bit of a hoo-ha r on social
media one of the contributors that Zayn
Malik he's aged since he's left 1d
that's cool it went wild maybe this is
the reason they're happening yeah and
finally the imposter he was there he's
there was our own adam boulton nigel
farage well the establishment tried to
kick me out about for number ten cent
read for i've turned up anyway you were
chatting to the last night were you yeah
i think i think good for him that he
gave money to eat earned up there should
be more people involved in these debate
Cameron's been trying to keep him out
and good for Farage making the game fun
and interesting that for our scored it
for Miliband of course he did Ed Miller
Beck it's nigel farage does more the
Conservatives win the general election
there'd be a referendum on europe he's
finished then so of course he's gonna do
it won't do any good up north where he's
been trying to run down labour he's
given labour a boost well let's move on
to our GAF of the week and this has a
musical theme we're staying with
politics you might have seen our
political mashups on Sky News but the
lib dems have given it a go themselves
with questionable results this hit
everyone in our country we've achieved
great things the Conservatives don't do
it labour don't do it in 2020 what sort
of them do we want to be it was on the
lib dem website it's not something that
it's happy it's gotta be a spook the
Tory Tory HCG all back Tory HQ must have
planted that all the way I because that
makes Nick Clegg's or even more idiotic
than normal remember the apology every
tuition fees which was parodied
ruthlessly on social media it's this why
they try to make the most of it they
would refer to that and this is uptown
funk popularly listen to downtown trash
political dad dancing it's
some reeks of desperation when a desktop
it's good that it does remind you the
guy on the dark or which is not good
yeah a lot of reaction so she made this
once saying that they've been paralyzed
by cringe by watching it it is
absolutely clear to making these dead
it's the young boat that they've lost
because of Jewish never gonna get em
back yeah what I'm gonna do NEX bring
back rickets and steam engine army
weirder here kids that need nhq should
be looking for a new job right let's
move on to our quiz of the week now can
you tell me where in the UK it's the
most friendly we'll find out after the
break before the break we asked who
where do you think is the most friendly
place in the UK these that these are the
choices what do you reckon well I know
Brian go well and I think it's very
friendly but I maguann I were talking
counter-intuitively Lee under the least
likely place is London so we're going to
go into London totally wrong ah Scotland
oh don't tell that to the Labour Party
from down and I come up there like
Scotland you don't go to all that built
on keen to Cambridge University they're
also pictured there they looks a
personality traits of people throughout
the UK and they found that it wasn't
just gotten it was those from the north
yeah well of course Scotland be more
agreeable make all your cooperative nose
in the south I'm better off because we
in the South pay all our taxes up the
Londoners beliefs were coming have you
got 20 quid I borrow but at least
welcoming in London but the most
broad-minded liberal and opened a new
experience I don't drink but oh dear
don't tempt him down that look right
right someone else who's a got a whole
load of new experiences on the horizon
including unemployment at Jeremy
Clarkson the brakes have finally been
put on his top gear career over two
weeks after he was suspended for what's
been described as a fracker was producer
a sheen time and the BBC says it won't
renew his contract skies Lisa kata has
more it was an unusual mode of transport
for the man who built his whole career
around cars and Jeremy Clarkson was
uncharacteristically
quiet the former Top Gear host the only
person not to have given his verdict I'm
am I'm offer out sorry it's the end of
an era for Jeremy Clarkson as one of the
BBC's most popular and successful stars
i think is an interesting debate that
petrol heads can have after weeks of
speculation the corporation's
director-general has revealed the
reasons for his ruling we all know that
Jeremy is a huge talent and has made an
extraordinary contribution to the BBC
his voice and voices like his have a
place an important place on the BBC but
not at any price the decision has thrown
the future of top gear one of the BBC's
biggest and most popular exports into
doubt with Clarkson's co-presenters
Richard Hammond and James may also
thinking about their future it's a
tragedy i'm sorry that what alt have
been a small incident sorted out easily
turned it's something big will you stay
at top gear but i don't want to talk
about that too much but i think we're
very much the three of us as a package
it works for very complicated reasons
that a lot of people don't fully
understand so that will require a lot of
careful thought north yorkshire police
are looking into the incident and will
take action when necessary Top Gear fans
will be left wondering if the program is
indeed bigger than the presenter we
mentioned about the police in that
report but it's a just been announced
that machine tyne and the producer has
said that he's not not interested in
pressing charges take us over here
although it's been dealt with but the
victim here was the producer who was
attacked it wasn't jeremy clark sand it
was a violent thug in a buggy and
anybody who wanted to defend him should
go to work should get assaulted by their
boss get their lip bust be abused be
threatened with a SAT and then see how
they feel I know the media has been
quite a rough-and-tumble world that I've
worked into 25 years they could surely
punched in the meadow I haven't but i've
worked in some very explosive situations
and actually I don't know Jeremy
Clarkson I've never watched Top Gear but
the BBC of can the most successful
export they've got that's going to cost
license paid tens of billions should be
a different role
and actually I think they should have
just been grown unsorted it up to try
different rule I've does you earn money
on a cashew so particularly odd to
Jeremy Clarkson to be fired immediately
just some plain and the BBC uses an
excuse to get rid of some who doesn't
fit in with a nice metropolitan liberal
view of the world absolutely not nothing
to do with those people in print you're
just you're condoning violence at work
and people being attacked and it isn't
it interesting that clocks and Gaza it
doesn't clock the Lord Hall Tony Hall
the boss ya know all along hits a junior
who he then says he's gonna get sacked
and threatens my god it's appalling
behavior every action oh don't you paint
the stories of the week at Kevin it's
you first this week thousands of hearts
were broken not mine particularly but
Zayn left one direction yeah it's like
but you know he's live the dream and yes
lots of young women are very very upset
lovely eyes really or anyway um but you
think he's lived a dream they finished
third in x factor in 2010 and yet they
became this great boy band he's earned a
fortune I mean he's got his own problems
of course where he was photographed with
a woman who wasn't his fiancée and he
left to sort that out but it is the end
of an era but these bands have a limited
shelf life anyway it's like national
mourning bands k well 22 there were 220
calls to employers asking for
compassionate leave well how did it is
days and I'd never heard of him until
this week out to the end when I heard of
his hairy I did meet them once in a lift
oh sorry sorry tuyter had no idea who
they were the floor there's a year we
are they wasn't there's a name you drop
just put it there you know there we are
I have it I always going to oversee very
good someone said you knew that was and
they told me I said I'm still none the
wiser yeah I'm sure as a palace I you
know I once met andrew pearson a little
either of you met Angelina Jolie and
prepared to drop that name no William
Hague William Hague big fan of course
but this is deed while she's yeah it was
an article in the new york times where
she's written about having her ovaries
removed because of the risk of cancer
very brave i think to share that and an
important thing because and she had a
double mastectomy because of
risk of breast cancer that which is in
her family and now the same because of
the risk of cancer and I'm not always a
great fan of Angelina Jolie and
Wittering on with William Hague trying
to launch all these campaigns but this
is very important and it will encourage
a lot of other women to discuss these
issues and it important read on with
their William Hague you mean trying to
stop women being raped and sexually
abused by walls exactly should be doing
more important things in consorting with
a sorority what the China essentially I
save ya save women young yeah cause it's
littered it's an interesting savagery to
raise as well because the menopause is
not a particularly sexy subject and a
lot of women don't I talking about it
and she's basically said you know I'm
going into it I'm taking off you know
she will help yeah yes talking about it
and I just beautiful and she's saying oh
so that's why it's important that she
did it and the reason I admire her she's
not one of these sublet celebrities will
just go along with the open of a milk
corn for a diversity no she's actually
actually actually gets involved in good
causes now someone else has been in the
news this week Richard the third he was
given a royal funeral I know Richard be
entered as he is now in in Leicester
after they Wu's body from underneath a
car but i always think he's king and
he's somehow being elevated why don't we
just call him what he was a tyrant a
dead spot killer a murderer a
cold-blooded thug should we be
celebrating his life and Martha Sam an
astonishing number what went to the
fantastic history he just can't bear it
because it's a monarch you know his
republicanism Dios back thousands of
years friends of mine have got family
unless said it was an amazing occasion
half of Leicester poured onto the
streets and actually yeah he may have
bumped up those young prince's I don't
know wasn't grounded and Shakespeare is
response for a lot of the demonization
of Richard the third but give him a
final resting place what's interesting
of courses the Queen sent a very junior
member the royal family there because of
course if she'd gone she'd have been
effectively and giving credence to his
line of succession which ain't us you
know that show it shows you though
there's no one broken line of monarchy
we just chop and change through the ages
but in fact the Lord for that you've
just condo and child murder there
right but let's look at the leicester
Mercury's take on on the story and there
it is Richard the third rentable we
carry some people been furious that
their journey to work was delayed or
affected by her so her Smike ingdom for
her Scott well staying with monarchy
Andrew you brought up the release of the
letters written by Prince Charles so
called spider letters that were written
to Miller's ministers yeah whether or
not they should be published he's been
writing letters to minister since he was
17 when Howard Wilson result was Prime
Minister and finally the Supreme Court
has ruled that we are entitled to see
them these are the spidery black
handwriting in his body black can read
because they say if he's lobbying which
is affected what he's been doing with
public has a right to know we will see
these letters they'll be redacted and
actually it's a Pyrrhic victory for the
guardian which took this because the
last Labour government just before it
fell changed the law so that his
correspondent with ministers can never
be seen if he is trying to meddle in
politics shouldn't he be held to account
no I think you shouldn't I think the
last Labour government shouldn't have
done that but the establishment always
rallies around the monarchy in this case
and I think they are a because he has
used his influence behind the scenes I
suspect to change government policy and
we are attacked to know that let's move
on to your people are things of the week
who you sending up who you sending down
a Kevin you're starting this week and
you're sending up James Corden he has
had a good week hasn't it as in the
stateís new chat show The Late Late Show
very very good reviews and he shows
charm can work and he can be a success
in the state where somebody like Piers
Morgan won't be because people like me
is that is he just a more likeable
personality oh yeah I know Piers Morgan
is a lot more likable James Gordon yeah
yeah latter-day mirror because of Piers
Morgan's so you're sending him up this
week but you're sending down F Salomon
remind us who is yeah this was a
Conservative candidate in Dudley North
he was caught having talks with the the
vile english defence league and
allegations of a phantom march against a
mosque so he could claim it was cool off
if you lie down with dogs you'll catch
fleas that's why he's out i right to
pick them out you agree if you're both
sending him down but you're sending up
this
week this is your choice Andrew there is
nothing like a day she got her Dame hood
yesterday long overdue I'm thrilled for
her and I have to say just to irritate
camera guy I was at the two parties you
had this week two Andruw here we are
ears another name and I just write it
but I'll be [ __ ] very nice she's good
she don't you become a day you have not
just one but two parties she had like
sure she's having even more map she had
a fantastic party at claridge's
name-drop and the night before she had a
party at come called five hartford
street that they wouldn't let requiring
i don't really see her down and I was
about 15 my mom gave me a copy of her
beauty books Joan Collins beautiful
slamming volume well you've clearly been
using cuz you look fantastic I don't she
look amazing Jane cause you just
sensational and it was a great gathering
at the greatness that's what having a
young husband does feel that you're fine
yeah hi there so I said to her up let me
go Joan well done at you're sending down
though Downton Abbey the end of an era
bye and good riddance it's gone on too
long I'm afraid I'm a big fan of it was
a big fan of it and we all love Maggie
Smith the great day countess ductus
whatever but I think Julian Fellowes has
flopped a dead horses my leg father
would have said for a bit you know what
I want the servant do they go hang out
when it's still good then they're not
letting it slip I think it's already I
thought the last Christmas special was
really boring and really tedious and
it's just becoming a bit past it we can
watch Paul dog anybody yeah he's got a
thing about that actor Ian Turner listen
richest this is a to know it's the
pictures of male menopause menopause
yeah I'm not interested in polar can I
don't don't impose your passions oh no
that's enough of this tour Judas we're
sending Downton Abbey dan what would
they say what would Lady Mary say I know
thank you both very much and thank you
i'm joining us for our review of the
week don't forget that you can catch
Kevin Andrew in action on the sky knees
press preview along with our other paper
reviewers as they take a look at first
look at the day's papers every evening
1030 and 1130 on Sky News we back with
much more next time sober now it's
goodbye from them goodbye and it's
goodbye for me goodbye
you